in the last video we talked about
allosteric regulation and allosteric
enzymes in this video I wanna give an
example of an allosteric enzyme which is
ATC ace which is short for aspartate
transcarbamoylase this enzyme catalyzes
the production of an carbamoyl aspartate
and hpo4 to- from its substrate
aspartate and carbamoyl phosphate which
is this thing I've drawn here ok so why
do we care about this reaction well the
reason we care about it is because it's
catalyzed by an allosteric enzyme ok and
in addition we're going to talk about
how this enzyme is regulated ok so why
is this reaction particularly important
well this is the this reaction here that
is catalyzed by ATC ace is the first
reaction first step in a pathway
dedicated to the production production
of primitive nucleotides oops not
forbidden nucleotides ok and
specifically the specific end product is
a particular permitting nucleotide which
is CTP so the end product is C T P ok
which is a primitive nucleotide so why
is this important well in the last video
we talked about how we would expect
enzymes to be regulated if one of the
things was if they are involved in the
first if they catalyze the first step
that's dedicated to a particular pathway
well a TCA is catalyzed the first step
of a pathway that creates an end product
CTP right so we want to make sure that
we only have this enzyme active when we
want to create CTP ok
in addition if there's already CTP
around we don't want this enzyme to be
active right what's the point of making
CTP if we already have some which brings
me to this idea of feedback inhibition
which are
probably already familiar with okay so
feedback inhibition okay or negative
feedback okay negative feedback is the
whole idea that the end product of a
pathway right will inhibit whatever
creates it right so it's it's the whole
idea here is that a TCAs is inhibited by
its end product CTP which basically if
there's a bunch of CTP around it'll
allosteric lis inhibits 80 CAS from
working because we don't want to be
dedicated to making more CTP if we
already have some okay which brings me
to this idea here which I'll elaborate a
little bit more on this in just a moment
so the allosteric effectors for ATC ace
well the first one is aspartate
aspartate why is it enough allosteric
effector for a TCS well its substrate
okay now I thought allosteric effectors
had to be activators or inhibitors well
how can they be substrates which is this
question here how can the substrate be
an allosteric effector well if you
recall what I'm going to write here this
substrate binds cooperatively right if
you recall that's what hemoglobin and
oxygen did right so oxygen was an
allosteric effector hemoglobin because
it would bind at one location the
affinity of the other subunits would
increase for oxygen so same idea here
with a sparked a aspartate a substrate
for a TCAs
and it actually binds to a TCS coop
cooperatively so once why aspartate
binds the others don't want the other
subunits on a TCS will have a higher
affinity for those aspartate okay so now
I want to talk about CTP or cytidine
triphosphate which is a particular
riveting nucleotide it's an allosteric
inhibitor
why we mentioned it over here is an end
product of the pathway okay so it's an
end product so end products right will
inhibit for the production
this is the idea that that this whole
pathway is dedicated to making CTP right
so if there's already CTP around right
it'll inhibit a TCS from working this is
a simple idea that don't make more don't
make more CTP if there's plenty around
so it's already plenty around
okay so cytidine triphosphate CTP is an
allosteric inhibitor of ATC ace okay now
the third thing that our third
allosteric effector here is it in
adenosine triphosphate which is ATP so
ATP is an allosteric activator well
while we have ATP as an allosteric
activator
well I'll ATP actually there's there's
there's two things here two reasons why
it actually activates it the first one
is that 18 a lots of ATP indicates it
indicates a high amount of energy right
and CTP and ATP is they're both
nucleotides and nucleotides are used to
make nucleic acids like DNA or RNA and
so so in order to have those processes
even occur you need energy so a lots of
energy is required in order to to you
know synthesize new nucleic acids from
nucleotides so it would make sense that
a high energy would sort of support this
idea of creating nucleotides to make to
make nucleic acids okay but the other
idea is a little bit clearer to kind of
see because high energy is not like the
most distinctive reason why ATP would
activate a TCAs
the other reason is that lots of ATP ATP
indicates lots of purines because ATP is
a purine nucleotide okay so if there's
lot
of purine nucleotides right for the
production of DNA RNA you need to have
purines and pyrimidines and you need to
have them in equal amounts right because
it when when in TNA when you order RNA
purines and pyrimidines make up the
Hydra hydrogen bound and those are
specifically DNA at least
double-stranded DNA you need one period
for every permitting that you have so if
you have a lot of purines then you need
to make sure that you make enough per
limiting to balance things out okay so
so here if we have lots of purine
nucleotides that means we need to make
for emitting nucleotides to even things
out right and then basically we need to
basically have the whole idea is that we
need to have we need equal amounts of
purines and pyrimidines okay so lots of
ATP indicates lots of purines if we have
a lot of purines we need to make sure
that the purine and pyrimidine sort of
amounts are balanced out so lots of ATP
would activate a TC ace to make CTP
which is a pyrimidine so that we have
then an equal number of per Imaging's
and purines okay excuse me so so knowing
all that let's think about about this
here right if this if this is the graph
of a velocity / substrate concentration
for for an allosteric enzyme
specifically a TCAs
think about this white line here that
i've drawn here it's the control with no
inhibitor no enact to it no activator
notice what's the shape of that if you
recall that is a sigmoid shape right
which is characteristic of an allosteric
enzyme
that's something to keep in mind now
notice this red line here would be it's
shifted to the left which means that it
will have a higher velocity at a lower
substrate concentration and that's
something we went over any other video I
won't elaborate too much on it here what
I what I want to point out is that the
red line is with the activator right so
if it's with the activator what is the
activator in this case the activator is
ATP so this red line here is with ATP
right the activator I'll put a little
plus sign here to put indicate activator
and the blue line is with the inhibitor
right the inhibitor okay or a little
negative sign there and the inhibitor is
I want to write negative I want I was
thinking negative feedback excuse me the
inhibitor is of course CTP okay so this
here would be with the inhibitor which
is CTP okay I hope that makes sense if
it doesn't make too much sense there's I
have a lab rated on it in the previous
videos check that video out okay so I
mentioned purines and pyrimidines just
to kind of refresh or maybe I should
have said this earlier but if you don't
ripple way to remember the purines and
the pyrimidines it's remember that the
purines are pure as gold so a and G are
the purines which are adenine the
nitrogenous bases adenine guanine right
those are the things that make up a
teepee and GTP right so those these
nitrogenous bases are the purine
nitrogenous bases that that you know
make up these purine nucleotides pure as
gold
so permitting nucleotides where I
remember that pyramids alright pyramids
have sharp edges notice how they have
like these little straight edges like
this so sharp edges what do they do
sharp edges
big cut so the sharp edges cut CU t
those are the things that are the
permitting nucleotides so that would be
cytosine the nitrogenous base is
cytosine uracil and thymine right they
make up the nucleotides CTP UTP and TTP
assume these are all triphosphates
anyway though this is sort of refresher
if you didn't already know this is
something to bear in mind as far as you
know being useful to how how you can um
remember what goes on with these
allosteric effectors so I hope that
video is helpful see you next time